do you just to appease the fans do you
have a favorite thing about nessa
um uh this this interview is gonna go
everywhere this is awesome
um okay a favorite thing about nessa
um you do have so many followers and
fans and a lot of them are also very
interested in your relationship with
nessa
yes yes you know this are you guys back
together
uh no no we're not back together um just
like kind of like i said with chase like
like i'll forget i've forgiven her for
it we like i wasn't
dating her so it's not really my choice
what she goes and
does like that's totally up to her it's
totally fine right um
i just was in in i guess like a
still like that fresh stage so i was
probably a little bit jealous i
definitely was jealous
but uh um yeah we're we're friends and
we we hang out
so that's awesome that's that's very
mature of you
do you see yourself ever getting past
what happened and getting back together
with her or is it just a no
i'm not gonna say like a no or yes i
think that
right now we're just friends and that's
kind of like how we're doing it
was was chase to blame for the breakup
as well
not at all okay what caught what caused
the breakup
um it was just we both kind of felt like
um
we needed to like grow up we were like
in a very
uh serious relationship but i don't
think
that either of us were like in the right
mindset like i was very very busy with
work all the time
and then as well with her like she was
starting a bunch of new
projects and everything like that and it
just got really like i guess
mentally stressful and stuff like that
so we were like why don't we both like
go our separate race for a little bit
grow up and then yeah
and then maybe get back together maybe
what do you have to say to all the fans
who are so invested
in your guys's friendship relationship
i guess thank you for the support like
i'm blessed for everyone that follows us
and likes our content comments on it uh
you
they have all changed my life like so
i'm nothing but grateful for them
yeah could we see her on trill or is she
someone that you're trying to
bring over i mean of course i i think
she would definitely be on trailer so
you'll definitely see her there
yeah did you did you see our interview
with bryce where he said that he thinks
you guys are going to get back together
do you think they'll get back together
yes
ah okay josh josh is
josh is a little simple
you say of course he would say that yeah
he he loves to uh
disturb the peace shout out advice for
doing that
um is it hard having people so invested
in your
personal life i mean
it definitely takes a toll because like
you start questioning your own decisions
when everyone has their own opinion on
it and it's like millions and millions
of people and they're always trying to
like
tell you like if you're wrong and you're
right and and i mean some people say
really harsh things some people will be
very kind about it but
uh it definitely takes a toll yeah
yeah do you feel like there's certain
things after
what happened with the whole chase
vanessa and charlie situation that
you won't post moving forward because
you do want to sort of protect
your peace and your privacy a little bit
i mean
it's kind of like a a weird situation
because i like to be very authentic and
that's like the brand that
i have been doing for quite a while now
so it's it's definitely like a tricky
situation
but um i love being authentic with my
fans and i love
to have them like see what's going on
and
definitely learn i guess from my
mistakes or learn from how i get up
and and keep going are you
wanting to date anyone else in the near
future you want to be single for a
little bit
um i think that i'm gonna stick to just
being single for right now but
um if there's ever a person that i have
you know
a connection with i'll definitely try to
date them
i hope that whatever happens like it's
gonna be
the best for me and the person involved
yeah do you just to appease the fans do
you have a favorite thing about nessa
um this this interview is gonna go
everywhere this is awesome
um okay a favorite thing about nessa
uh i think that just like our humor is
very similar when
when we like joke around together so
that's like why i wanted to keep her as
a friend because like i think she's very
funny
and that i just like laughed very hard
when i'm around her so
i would say that that was such a good
answer this interview is probably gonna
go everywhere are you ready for that
yeah i'm gonna see it all over the place
changing gears a little bit there has
been a little bit of criticism
i feel like over the past couple weeks
with social media stars and with
tick-tock stars and
there was that huge party at the the
hype house
what did you make of that
first of all um i mean i think that
as creators like people try to you know
like make cool content and they try to
collab still and do all that but i think
when those situations happen you just
need to take away from it from like with
a
i guess learning mentality i went up
with a mask uh
went out to the outside area filmed my
montages with price and then i left
um i didn't really participate in the
partying that night just because i was
in a bad mood
um why are you in a bad mood i don't
know what it was
i was just kind of pissed off like it
was just like one of those days
like i remember coming out and i knew i
think it was a little bit because of
like
paparazzi was outside and i knew they
were going to try to spin something on
me because i was leaving and dropping
off nessa at home
so i like came out with her and then
they instantly were trying to be like oh
you guys are a couple you guys are a
couple and they're like asking all these
kind of like
questions that i just like did not want
to answer i was trying to go home i had
to wake up really
i needed to be able to wait for this
interview to answer them all yeah
exactly i was like i gotta i gotta wait
for this
big interview what are you talking about
do you feel bad at all for going to the
party
or do you feel like you were so safe
that you don't really want
i kind of like didn't really associate
because everything was
mainly happening inside and i just kind
of like walked up
did my bits and went out but um yeah
have you learned anything about yourself
having been under such
like a crazy microscope lately uh
i think that i've definitely learned
quite a few things
i mean uh definitely like watch i guess
what i do and say because like every
time i go even if it's not me filming
like i gotta monitor myself now so it's
like
i'll go outside and or i'll be working
out and like
paparazzi will come out so it's like
it's like a definitely
different type of experience because
two three months ago we weren't getting
that and now we are so
i mean it's kind of cool like uh people
like to have like people that care about
you that much how they make paparazzi
videos about you
so like again like grateful for that but
um
you know i'm just at the end of the day
i'm happy to be here
do you feel like you have to almost not
be in public so much with nessa because
it keeps
driving this narrative of people wanting
you guys to get back together
um i think that like honestly right now
i just don't go out in public a lot
like just because of everything that's
going on so it's not really an issue
but uh when covid is all over i guess
i'll
i'll have to see about that